ladies and gentlemen it's your host Jake
Watson
you know Sam saying that it's over there
hey guys what's going on back at the
table at the corridor cast we've got Sam
we've got Niko we've got Ren and we've
got a great episode just for you so
thanks for joining and thank you to
today's sponsor story blocks for
sponsoring this video more on them later
but all you need to know for now is
there a members-only website that is
your one-stop shop for all of your stock
photo needs yeah I use them for videos
like legitimately yeah mine uses all the
time and uh what does that's why there's
a sponsor but this isn't a sponsored
segment all right guys what's been going
on this week a lot going on lots of
that's been going on we've been working
on this deep fake Keanu Reeves video mmm
that's been pretty cool by the way did
you guys see not that first clip from
The Shining with Jim Carrey but the
second one no Jim Carrey yeah so his
name's control shift face and he's been
doing deep fakes and of everybody out
there he's kind of turned it more into
an art form than anybody else has
because he's picks things that just make
sense and he swap identities like for
example in the the movie The Last Action
Hero if there's a scene where they go
into Blockbuster and the kids turn
against Arnold Schwarzenegger that he's
an actor and he's like yeah right he's
like look look look he's like hey
where's that like where's your action
films there's like over there he goes
he's like oh perfect let's go like a
terminator and they pull it over and
they look at this big covered cut out
it's Sylvester Stallone as The
Terminator
oh so then the guy goes and he does a
scene from The Terminator with Sylvester
Stallone to show you what it would have
been like in that world so that's always
been doing is he's been like finding
these moments and movies where it makes
sense to swap identities for example so
Fight Club
when Edward Norton is talking to Brad
Pitt he has parts where Edward Norton
and Brad Pitt's face morphed back and
forth oh I haven't seen that one yeah
but he just recently did a scene from
The Shining most people saw the first
Moore's just Jim Carrey as Jack
Nicholson typing but they had a new one
where it's like a six-minute long scene
and it's the baseball-bat scene where
you know Jack Nicholson's like walking
around talking to Shelley Duvall she
starting to freak out more and more and
more and eventually hits him with a
baseball bat and he falls
the stairs and it is incredible the
scenes amazing like it's just that I
need to watch a little movie I've only
seen it in parts but like Sam it's like
seeing Jim Carrey as Jack Nicholson just
makes you really want to watch the whole
movie with Jim Carrey as Jack Nicholson
yeah if they remake it did you do the
voice as well
no it's Jack Nicholson's voice yeah do
we have Internet Christian do we have
Internet you don't have internet guys
they're fixing the Internet outside of
the building
I lied they're not actually doing
reconstruct you go see you part of the
city yeah Nico so you've actually been
talking with that guy
yeah because we've been working on our
own Keanu Reeves deep fake idea that's
been it's been code along really nicely
but there's like there's so many ways
you could make a deep fake okay look at
this guy's Wow
yeah it looks super good thick Joe to
the camera it's perfect show it to the
camera that one wait the Internet's back
yeah this is a good clip for us to
actually a screencap it's control-shift
face we're able to actually pull up a
jump to our four minutes from this
distance it's coming up right now yeah
right now couldn't quite see it I've
been doing this he's been doing it for
about as long as we have which say like
four weeks for this channel is like a
month and a half old
Wow dang well I still feel like his
channel is kind of like the name in the
game for for deep fakes yeah look how
good that looks it's nuts and like a
little bit of Jack Nicholson in that
face yeah but it's also Jim Carrey's
face so is this a face swap because it's
a little less faithful but very
realistic Nico well one thing I've
learned is there's a lot of different
techniques can do and one of the
techniques give you gives you a very
realistic face like what you're seeing
here but it's not as faithful to the
faces on there it recreates a face in
general really well and makes that face
look real you see Jim Carrey's like
Ventura coming through right there but
it but it's why it still kind of looks
like Jack Nicholson even though you're
like well that's a Jim Carrey I mean
it's an amazing scene well like the way
it handles the light on the face yeah
like that that's the best part but
you're right I see what you're saying
it's like not quite as
faithful as it could be but it makes
concessions in order to make it more
photo real with the scene and I feel
like at the end of the day it makes them
more a better like a better shot right
it's because it's like you have a better
emotional reaction when the face looks
more realistic yeah if it's not entirely
Jim Carrey you can still see that you're
looking at Jim Carrey and so your
checklist on your brain just kind of
accepts it mmm six there fall who's not
stuntmen reacted yeah so I gotta admit
the what that the face looks a little
bit better than what we've been done so
far
mm-hmm but we could you know it's like
we're jockeying for Best deep fakes on
the internet right now yeah definitely
what are we gonna do with this Keanu one
next week oh well the techniques I'm
using with the Keanu one I've actually
trained two models one that's more
faithful to Keanu's face and one that's
more realistic to just looking like a
face in general it still looks like
Keanu but not as much like sometimes it
just looks like a guy that looks like he
anew it doesn't actually look like Keanu
but that lets me have both what you know
technique that you saw there for Jack
Nicholson I can do that technique for
some shots that require it to be real
and then I can go with the other
technique that for some shots that
required to look like Keanu and then
just balance the two but it's been
really fascinating been learning
actually a ton about artificial
intelligence this past week what have
you learned well there's a lot of crazy
stuff out there I've learned that it's
like all powerful and it's going to fix
all our problems and it's the end of the
world all right so like world problems
here's what I've learned is that it
basically started with GPUs becoming
more and more powerful and more and more
prevalent because CPUs aren't very good
at doing like gigantic number crunches
they're good for like following
instructions but when you just have like
a wash of like a trillion numbers and
you need to like multiply them all by
5.6 and like a GPU is better at that
than a cpu GPU is basically a lot of
tiny CPUs packed onto one big card GPU
is literally another computer with a
motherboard Ram processors all that
stuff is basically yeah
and it's like instead of like if you're
lucky you have like eight or twelve
processors in your regular computer a
GPU will have like two or three thousand
processors and each processor is kind of
dumb but when you have thousands of them
each doing a dump task can do that task
really really quickly yeah I always
thought it was just kind of like an
opponent I guess I never really knew
what it did it's like a Russian dog like
subset of components yeah I always like
to imagine that you li are just but you
literally are buying a tinier computer
that goes in your computer just for the
purpose of processing so it only called
a graphics processor because it was
originally intended to render graphics
yeah because the calculations are doing
for graphics are just like a lot of
vector math and other types of basic
math okay and that's what the GPU is
really good at just do it look at it
doing lots of math um but yeah like I
said it's literally a motherboard with
processors on it and RAM that just goes
into your computer so it's a little tiny
year computer friends got four of them
in there I no longer have the most
powerful computer either
it's weird I go through bouts where I
have that problem a lot for like a
couple days and then I'll go like two or
three weeks without a single issue it's
a motherboard problem we've been able to
narrow down to like my motherboard crazy
but um yeah but anyway so with with
artificial intelligence basically it so
it started machine learning is basically
the other thing that was like the
turning point here and machine learning
is basically where you make a couple
different types of programs you make a
program that makes programs and it's
just like kind of random program kind of
randomly mutates those little programs
and make another program that then
grades those programs so you set those
little programs to tasks they do a job
and then they go past that little like
teacher program that's come back okay a
plus B minus F b plus a plus and like
you know basic grades them and the ones
that do really well it takes those back
in and when okay that's how we built
those let's now make those the new
blueprint for our new little programs
were going to make and will once again
do little alterations and it keeps doing
that over and over and over and little
by little creates a a world of little
programs
there's no video from our Kroeber that
he just put out like a week ago that
really simplifies and explains what
machine learning is because he made him
and this other guy named Jibril made
this app on how to basically guess have
you guys seen this video he made an app
on how to guess Baseball signs you know
like there's the guys telling the other
guy to like steal bases but they do like
all these complicated maneuvers and to
try to like disguise which series of uh
like one yeah yeah it's like like here's
the here's the first one the next one
will be like whether or not you should
go for it and they're able to make this
app that was able to decode even the
most complicated base signs hmm and or
stealing signs that's super cool watch
that yeah like and it's just mark just
being all X I'd like oh my god my app
works he's like watching the guy who's
like plugs in the signs that he did and
then after doing it like three or four
times the app learns what moves are the
right moves it is steel that could
actually be really valuable to a
baseball organization yeah like the
video goes over that but basically as
long as you can have what's called like
your ground truth you're like this is
what your answer should look like and
you can give that to the computer and
give it the thing that has to practice
as long as you can go back and compare
it to something they can basically work
on getting there and making it look good
so you can kind of train a computer to
do almost anything as long as you have
these inputs and outputs part to look at
and of course plenty of processing time
so there's all this crazy stuff like
Nvidia has an algorithm out or basically
can just like paint like colored areas
and then like this is a car this is a
tree this is a road it goes okay I know
what cars and trees and roads look like
and then it draws it Christian when you
type in p IX number two p IX it looks
like it's mspaint and he like draws a
line and fills the bottom half with
brown in the top half of blue and then
you like draws another line and makes
that like you're looking at this really
beautiful landscape of mountains it
looks like someone's nephew just
completed their first like like dude
Photoshop tutorial that's like the end
result in my opinion this is like look
at that
this thing no yes wait wait wait go back
sorry go back the image on the top the
the it was human generate doesn't even
generated well go to the one that you
can actually do the dance was human
generated and then they put it against a
promising learning process actually the
well the top might not have been human
generated by Bentley just drawing over a
photo labeling spots okay here's where
cars are here's a lamppost are but just
watch for a second you'll see what
happens so regards to where that at the
top is human generated uh-huh it's
basically the colors designate areas and
now they're changing the car type
they'll change the road type they'll
change the tree type
it's insane have you seen the
interactive version of this yeah they
have the lowest yeah like that one is
like the little like is a maybe even a
better example of kind of what this is
but a lot of people like you know people
working on this are now having to like a
struggle and come to terms with like
what they're working on because you were
eventually you're essentially inventing
processes that can like well here I'll
give you an example so this thing right
here you designate a part of the image
and then the algorithm fills it in with
its knowledge of life like it's kind of
like having a really good painter where
you're like here I'm gonna block out a
picture this should be a person here a
hill here and it's a stream here they go
okay and they know how to paint a person
they know how to paint the mountain they
not a face just for people who are
listening only basically we have an MS
paint equivalent where there's just a
two tone you know three tone rendering
of like a street where the sky is blue
and the ground is green and there's some
cars that are purple and the machine
learning has taken that at taken that
and created a full detailed picture with
all the shading and the lighting and the
different types of color textures that
you would find in a regular photo now
it's doing it with faces users basically
just taking like somebody's sketch and
drawing it into an actual picture much
like how an artist could take some of
these outline and then paint in with
like oil paintings like up very photo
real thing that blew up a few months ago
of like all you had to do was draw like
a stick figure of a cat and it would
automatically create this rendering of a
cat for you like that resembled your
weird stick figure yeah yeah he was like
kind of weird because
it was like obviously weird and
disfigured but also still kind of
photorealistic so I want to give you
guys an example of something I heard
about it was a that uses this in a way I
could be considered malicious and this
is like I said this is one of the
problems as people open this it's not
really a Pandora's box because I don't
considered an really negative thing but
this power right its power to just
generate anything
somebody took this algorithm which is
open source anybody can grab that and
they're like okay well I'll just make
another algorithm here that can
recognize clothing and then it knows how
to fill things in so I'll just have it
fill in the nude body under clothing and
it's literally an algorithm we can give
it a picture of a person and it will
make that person naked things will you
see there we just draw on the road it
draws a Roady draw on the hyatt draws an
eye it's like drawing the shape of the
person and it draws them you got a love
humanity it's like let's take this
really complex work of like machine and
human capability that's like the epitome
of what we can do graphically right now
and someone makes nudies out of it
identities awash on the internet now
like the concept of human identity is no
longer like this sacred thing it's just
you're another like it or not you're
another just number among billions Dewey
yeah yeah and yeah to a computer you're
just the data so yeah yeah well it makes
you think also too it's like what's the
value of like information at this point
when it's like imagery and things like
this like is data from everyone
everyone's social media accounts and
stuff like that all converging the one
thing it's like what we do on YouTube
it's like how is one second of our video
different than like one second of
someone else's like home videos like
they're more value to this data or is
this all just like a big wash of just
like effectively equal numbers that
programs like this can now start to
absorb here's the value will it make you
buy something the end yeah ice cold
rip free will you know I think we're
seeing a big backlash though to Algar
in certain ways mainly in recommendation
algorithms I think for the longest time
people are kind of putting up with
recommendation algorithms and it's
gotten to the point where the companies
that make those have forced them upon us
so much repeat like but the
recommendation algorithms haven't gotten
better they're still crap wait what
recommendations are you talking all of
them
no like specifically okay I'm talking
about YouTube's recommendation algorithm
I'm also talking about Netflix is
recommendation algorithm talking about
Spotify the recommendation algorithm now
Spotify does have some winners once
while they all have winners once in a
while they like they're not completely
dysfunctional we're talking about
content yeah exactly like content that
they think you might enjoy to consume
right and you're not talking like
advertising not advertising content they
think you might enjoy watching really
content that keeps you on their site
longer that way they can advertise which
is actually kinda where the problem
comes from because like all these
algorithms have ulterior motives that
and the motives aren't give you your
best videos that you want to watch like
that's not what these algorithms are
motivated to do and so for the longest
time we're like we're putting up with
annoyance for the sake of our
entertainment and like you're seeing a
huge rise now in like channels that just
curate stuff like human beings that are
putting in the fricking time to browse
other people's art follow people that
make it stuff and then pick up good
things and just curate them and like
there's all these issues like people are
making millions literally just taking
other people's stuff and like react and
game channels yeah exactly what your
channels eat your channels yeah that's
what they call it in the ad world well
we said a feature channel yeah feature
other people's work yeah yeah what a
disgusting format reacting to go make
something yourself we are adding I mean
okay obviously I'm being a little
facetious here because we do the VFX
react series and we enjoy it we think
it's good content because we're adding a
new perspective and new information that
everyone else doesn't might not know
yeah because there is the shared
experience of what we are reacting to
the idea is that they've already seen
what reacting to you know they've
already seen those movies know our
opinion on it it's like having a
magician coming to your house and and
you a magic show for an hour or for 15
minutes and be like hey but it's real
it's with anything you know it's like
you see that over there let me do that
with it but she didn't know that about
it you know it's like that's the
experience that at least I get being an
on VFX artist hearing you guys talk
about the yeah
stuff in the videos everyone exactly
like truthfully they're not really react
videos like we're reacting like the only
reason why we're using the word react is
because that's like that's the the
clickbait name like I've heard it here
first it's like this is the name of the
game it's like that's that's what I mean
it's the easiest way to communicate
roughly what's gonna happen to somebody
else who's never seen one before in
reality what they are is their breakdown
videos we're gonna break down how the
effects are yeah but no one wants to see
a breakdown video because you associate
that with being boring yes that's very
true and I guess I do have some funny
reactions but yeah you know like we're
seeing this huge rise of curating like
being a thing and like it's honestly in
every meeting we have with YouTube but
for the longest time that's been like
the one thing I recommend with them it's
either a expose the algorithm to the
user so the user can for example go like
you know it's a day I don't want to see
some cool music videos I never watch
music videos by no there's cool ones let
me give you some inputs of the music
videos I like and you spit back some
music videos I think I like based on
that input okay let me play with the
algorithm yeah
but there's no way to do that there's no
way for me to be back I could go for
some cool music you guys all react you
know I just saw a video about carpentry
I wonder if there's some cool carpentry
videos out there but it's like I don't
watch videos about carpentry so I don't
ever get recommend and channels are
legitimate out yeah yeah instead you put
an hour's worth of time into searching
for these videos and then YouTube thinks
that your new obsession for the rest of
the month is carpentry videos music
videos I know I I'm starting to use
incognito mode frequently for almost
everything whether it's just like casual
like Google searches or even now for
YouTube I actually have like two sub
accounts that are attached to my email
so like each time I pull up like kids
videos my son oh I always swap over to
that one first before Sesame Street like
it's just like I know I would be great
if there is if they recognize that you
have to do this now you want to leave
those cookies in the cookie jar yeah
cookies yeah actually valve announced
this week that they were they're
introducing this part of their service
called steam labs wait hold up yeah this
is one day oh yeah this is gonna allow
users to do the work as a team ya know
to test out different work-in-progress
projects one of those things being a
recommended feed one of the first three
things that they're experimenting with
is a is experiments using machine
learning to recommend new games based
upon what you've previously played and
they're gonna let steam users basically
contribute back what they think the
recommended feed should do mmm
interesting part me feels like hey you
know what steam you guys make like
billions upon billions of dollars maybe
you guys should just like pay some
people to do that so I don't have to do
it for you for free so you can make more
money is like this is like the this is
but why would they do that when they can
do it for free I know right I know
exclusive stuff but this is like the
unashamed version of like the YouTube
algorithm where it's like they are
literally selling a product and they
literally want you to help them make
their algorithms to sell you products
better but then they're and they're open
about it this would be a chance for
people to go hey I haven't played logic
games before or I haven't traded like
first-person shooters to show me a bunch
of the good ones yeah this would be a
chance for people to do that here yeah
that's true so I used to be really
against like targeted ads for instance
like unlike platforms whatever I was
like I don't want them like learn about
my habits and like and I still like
agree with that mindset however like
instagrams been really good lately for
finding like things that I actually want
to buy and serving them to me as ads
like there's this one random thing I
don't even really know why it served it
to me but it was like this you know
those little like pin things where you
have like a like a grid of like a
million pins and you put on your face in
it oh man that but it's just 2d and it's
for like putting it into like
complicated cars and it makes an outline
of that you can put on
a piece of wood or cardboard draw the
outline of that and now you have a
perfect cutout to go into that corner I
have zero need for this but oh my god
did I want it that sounds super cool and
like they have like these tiny little
like yellow frisbees that are this big
that you put in your pocket that are
like actual good frisbees that you can
like throw like a couple hundred yards
Wow or a couple hundred feet I don't
know the parts be impressive I don't
know that's two football field that's
ridiculous part so then I take a step
back and I'm like well okay if that is
the result of like you know the sort of
the targeted sort of tracking of my
habits like is it really that bad
I guess that is the bad if until it's
good yeah that's what they say but I
always thought like oh you're just
you're just saying that that's the end
goal but now it's actually getting to
that end goal so I don't know yeah I
mean this has always been the catch-22
with ads yeah well all we really want to
do is sell you things that you want
every sales like why you have to be so
mean yeah but we're just going to make
your life easier
it it is a it is a catch-22 that that
kind of brings us to our next topic guys
yeah so this is the catch-22 this is it
right here it's happening before us
Google Voice all right Google home so
this we're all familiar with Google
Voice and alone now Alexa play played
Esposito Alexa volume 10 so there is
there's some information that reveals a
little bit more about how these Google
home and Google Voice devices may be
listening to you a little bit more than
you think okay okay yeah turn off all
the lights came out let me explain how
this came out so Google in an effort to
improve their service they hire language
expert contractors to review tiny
snippets of wait of home and
Google assistant recordings to better
understand different variations in
language yeah it's actually like
identify the the words being use exactly
so turns out that one of these
contractors was keeping all this stuff
all this all these recordings that they
received and then also somehow getting
more and then they leaked it all to a
Belgian public TV network and in these
recordings was things that were not
should not have been recorded as in they
were not recorded after the wake word
was was said or activated things like
business calls private conversations
Waits and before you say it's not a big
deal let me bedroom conversation side
even domestic violence situations guys
so here's the thing the Google home
privacy policy says that data only
leaves the device and goes to be
recorded when the wake word is detected
now having all of these recordings that
aren't part of that clearly indicates
that that this is not always the case
and that it's recording far more than
weren't those what people accidental
wake words though like weren't they like
accidentally triggered like obviously no
one actually said the wake word but the
device thought it heard it to you this
way like realistically if you were
Google yeah and you could easily just
turn around and say oh that was an
accident
the AI must have misunderstood you we
recorded a bunch more than we should
have which would allow us to record a
bunch more about you which allowed us to
serve you way more ads which allow us to
sell more so I allowed us to there is
I'm extremely skeptical that they just
recorded just because if like yeah I'm
just very skeptical I knowing how good
journalism is aka how bad journalism is
like knowing that the Spanish news media
thought our Boston Dynamics a robot
video was real and said as much in there
like primetime show wait they did I
thought they were just talking about the
viral video the first time it like they
reported on it they thought it was real
hot person like I didn't really like
so I don't know what Belgium's any
better but uh I just I very much doubt
that any journalist gives any crap
whether or not this is actually like
illicit recording or if this just makes
a story better to call it elicits
recording when in reality something
could've said hey Google and then like
it's less about it and like then like
they keep talking so it keeps listening
buts waiting for like a command that I
can understand or you know somebody's
getting up with like long recording like
probable but here's the anything more
like think what you're getting at is the
fact that like there is zero regulatory
oversight this on these companies so
it's like the only thing we have to
trust when they say that you know oh
they're not recording anything else is
just their word and obviously they have
incentive to no no you can easily just
monitor your network traffic okay I mean
I'm just saying it's like yeah okay so
you can figure that on your own but
nonetheless they let you go no average
person is gonna do that no but if they
figure out some sort of way not an
average person you can still set it up
and just do a little test by yourself
this that's very true you can just very
easily mind if you if you wanted to
verify whether this article was true or
not we could spend a day tomorrow and we
could make a whole video about it and
figure it out within a day at work okay
lemon I yeah that's not really the point
I was making sure oh it's like I I agree
with you I think because it's like you
can definitely measure this is something
that is actually explicit and
substantial like you can measure whether
or not it's recording you but you know
engineers who work in these companies
are very smart and can find ways around
that maybe like recording stuff but only
send it out the next time you know you
say hey Google or whatever is like my
point is there is no oversight they
could do whatever they want
true but they've also actually torn
apart the hardware and like you can see
how it's why I like you you know for
example to record something in store it
requires you to have some sort of memory
solution to do so and you can look at
the hardware structure and see if that
exists and maybe people have they've
taken these things apart and looked at
how they're why they don't they don't
store it on the device right there isn't
a way to store it on the device yeah
yeah for the record I do agree with you
I'm kind of just playing devil's
advocate because it was the same thing
that happened with you know people are
like oh my phone's listening to me
because I was talking about
jet skis and now I'm getting jet ski ads
on Facebook Facebook's listening test
like you know man you were drunk and it
was midnight and he wanted a jet ski I
brought home those rake on headphones
huh
and I and Wendy had not touched him okay
move all groan all we done was talk
about that and then she went on to her
phone and guess what she got served a
race on that oh it's I mean yes how do
you tell you I'll tell you how I'll
explain that for you okay explain we
just did a sponsored segment with them
uh-huh
right now they're spending money on
advertisements and usually when you do
that you kind of cover up you cast a
wide net
right so it's total questions because
they're spending money on advertisements
right now here's exactly how it happened
you have emails third ray conning them
they are signed to your IP address where
your phone is pulling the data from oh
snap there's actually and that's that's
the other thing you have a gmail account
like you can feel pretty safe that
whatever Google home device you have in
your house is doing like maybe point one
percent of the damage that your gmail
that's way more in personal information
than just like I don't read aloud my tax
returns in my living room but I do store
them on like an email account so I have
a friend who works at Google and like
the analyzing the market the the area
that kind of figures out whether or not
you saw an ad how many times you saw an
ad for like say a movie trailer and
whether or not you went and actually saw
that movie and you can do all these
different things to try to hide the fact
of whether you saw the movie or not and
it will know Google knows you know what
else people should know Ren that this
video is brought to you by story blocks
that's right another thing you should
know about is today's sponsor story box
now if you are a video creator or a
content creator of any kind story blocks
is a members own
the one-stop shop for all of your stock
video needs now story box offers video
clips b-roll After Effects templates
motion backgrounds from a global market
place all over the world and all of
their assets are high quality 4k Studio
qualities you're never gonna have to
worry about whether they're too
expensive or whether they're low quality
and the best part is they offer
unlimited downloads meaning that you can
use story box as much and as often as
you want well you are a member if you
decide you don't want to be a member
anymore guess what all the stuff you
used all the stuff you downloaded it's
all good to go it's all royalty-free
isn't that great
we use it all the time over here at
corridor digital we use it on corridor
videos we use it on corridor crew videos
heck you might even see some shots right
here in the corridor cast so if you guys
are ever interested in a great place to
get stock footage consider story blocks
just go to story box comm slash corridor
cast or click the link in the
description of this video and you'll be
well on your way
all right back to the cast let's do this
and we're back and soaking I'm loose
it's you guys don't know I'm permanently
there's no air conditioning in here we
close the door and there's five dudes
temperature inside here like it's like
almost 90 degrees up for sure that's not
going to tell me the temperature do you
guys want to solve the problem with
Google assistant or do you want to move
on to it oh my god keep talking about
the basic question and then I filled in
the rest of the words with your voice
God hey Siri what's the temperature in
here I need it I need a smart
thermometer yeah it's yeah it's gonna
look thermometer in here no so you guys
aren't concerned at all that that Google
assistant isn't used what could be
considered nefariously I I don't think
it was use nefariously well if you're
the President of the United States
States you're not gonna have one in the
Oval Office and if you are you're pretty
stupid president you've already done so
if you are these mistakes it says let's
suppose a hypothetical you're the
president United States you find out
about this do you call the head of
Google and say hey what's going on here
give me the give me the truth you know
what my boss Hey yeah what up Sanjay
give me the deets would you do that
would you be at least concerned enough
to do that yeah and then they'd send
some like idiot to testify and then like
we get no information Sam knows what's
up
Wow my votes for you Sam how you guys
want the world to be though no I mean
for the phone they send the CEO of the
entire council worth some lawyer if your
facebook no for Google to I know my
Google just went through this and that
was the word like this the senator is
grilling them or like so what about like
how you know what my iPhone is doing is
like we don't make iPhones for this
brings up this brings up that issue
which is even if it was recognized that
this wasn't being used for a complete
100% nice-guy purposes and and then all
of a sudden you know you did need to
have some body step in and handle it do
you think that Congress would even be
capable not yet competently to handle
something like this I think in 10 years
yes and but right now no I'd agree with
that yeah cuz they're always behind well
I feel like the law works the laws I
always trying to catch up well I mean
that's just the nature of the law right
you know you're not gonna just make laws
before things happen right right exactly
I mean that's that's specifically why
there's a lot of fear over the lack of
regulation on AI yeah because by the
time something happens to cause
regulation it's gonna be too late I
don't think we can say much more on
Google huh okay okay what's the answer
you've been trying to ask us I've been
trying yeah I I find myself just not
being worried cuz I don't think it's
gonna end up bad worst case scenario
they serve
yeah that's the real like truth of this
all they're trying to do is just try to
get more information about you so that
they can make more money basically
they're just trying to figure out if
they're if or if not to send you a link
to Infowars what it really mean this is
whether or not you're okay with losing
privacy because that's what's happening
is that we're slowly having our privacy
eroded away yeah but it's a nice neutral
big corporation not your neighbor like
that's the privacy I care about my
neighbor
you know when they see me walking around
my underwear at midnight it's like
that's that but Google it's fine I think
well known amongst billions of numbers
they don't care millions of people
walking around in my underwear there's
no privacy in a crowd regardless of
whether not everyone can see her face I
mean that's say Osama bin Laden was
hiding in plain sight boys you're right
exam if he had a Google home okay well
didn't you say something about the
boosted Rev yeah but that's like I got
the question okay Iran was here opinion
on the pint orders being delayed once
again okay okay so a future motion the
company who makes the one-wheel which is
pretty much one of our most favorite
things ever at least it is for me they
have their next-gen model which is
basically a simplified version it's
smaller cheaper and coming out negative
months from now just perpetually yeah it
was supposed to come out I forget like
in April and then into May and they've
just been slowly delaying it later and
later and honestly I it's one of those
things that I think it's whatever it
takes because they are one of the few
companies that are designing and
building a hundred percent of their
products here in the United States
mm-hmm and it yeah there's a lot of
problems that come with that they can't
just like just send it to the army to
make a whole new PCB board and just have
it all printed out give me a million
orders by next Tuesday like army yeah
you know just Chinese army although
Chinese army
my knees are me yeah like when you're
when you're manufacturing in China
that's the you get a lot of those
advantages most companies manufacture in
China because of that but one wheel or
future motion they make all of their
devices here in Sacramento no not
Sacramento San Jose San Jose they design
them in Santa Cruz that's their
headquarters in but there are actual
factories in San Jose so it's all
manufactured here and I imagine they're
going through some quality control
issues where it's like their their
design has been final for quite some
time they've been building it and
they've been trying to get to work but
every now and then they might find like
maybe this one screw they're having a
problem with like one out of every ten
screws breaks after two hundred miles
mm-hmm and that's terrible because that
means all right they ship out all their
uh their units they sold you know ten
thousand units and now every single like
ten percent of those ten thousand units
are gonna have to come back and they're
gonna have to fix and they have to pay
for all that through their own warranty
program so you're telling me that in the
state of California they're experiencing
delays from manufacturing that brought
on by their product or by the state
regulations
I was thinking mostly just from their
products oh like that's just the natural
way of making a product you you have to
like find out all the edge cases or as
many edge cases as you can of problems
and things that can go wrong and then
help mitigate them before you actually
ship your product we should hire we
should ask them to hire us as the edge
boys send us a bunch of pints figure out
what's wrong with them and there's Jack
I've tried yeah the thing is though like
for everybody that ordered one like they
were all given shipping X like estimates
and then like literally up until that
day it says that day and then once he
hit that day just boom bums forward to
weeks like oh but here's the thing the
exact same thing happened with the XR
the exact same thing happened with the
plus I'm going backwards in time through
their model version history and the
exact same thing happened with the v1
yeah which was their Kickstarter model
so I guess they need to estimate their
dates a little more buffer always
under-promise and over-deliver try not
to over promise and under deliver yeah
yeah so how long is it gonna be oh I
have no idea I didn't I didn't I didn't
pre-order one I have no need for one cuz
I have an X R yeah cuz we're cool
Wow I'd like to have a pint is that can
go on an airplane with it yeah okay well
along those lines guess who else is
trying to make moves
boosted Wow yeah they announced you
didn't let me guess guess who else is
trying to make moves so this is actually
know who it is
[Laughter]
[ __ ] electric scooter called the
boosted Rev it's gonna have it's gonna
have a 1500 watt power it's gonna have
22 miles of possible range it's gonna go
up to a top speed of 24 miles an hour
and it costs $1600 what do you guys
think of this I think it's a missed
opportunity to call it scooted actually
that looks like a pretty solid scooters
especially compared to these other ones
we've been using that have I mean that
don't for a second let me let me preface
this really quick the reason I said
scooters are for [ __ ] is because
we've been working with some guys who
made what we thought to be really good
scooters you know all right and we we
had a couple I mean yeah but also their
they were great they and they were great
they work and then they eventually held
me lately and fall apart within
basically about three to four months of
actual real life use so there's that
whole element and then there's the other
four and now we only really have
basically one yeah we still we started
with four five five I started with five
and now there's one that's we start with
five but the first one malfunctioned
pretty much right away right in the
first like two days yeah exactly and and
we got them in November of last year so
it's been about like eight months so
either way so there's that and then but
I just had an emotional reaction every
time I see a scooter I just think about
the piles and piles of jumps and birds
and limes that I see around our city or
here they just pile up like like dust it
like likes and you know then that dirt
that just gathers on the side of the
curb and so I'm just like there there's
a malicious side to me that really wants
to just
steal those scooters disassemble them
harvest their batteries and use the
batteries for something else we should
do that let's put on like black bandit
mask that cover our our our face stop
recording so actually we don't have the
mens rea oh guys I mean it's like it's
just one of those like to entertain my
head is like look at this pile of six
scooters here no one would say a word if
I just pulled up in my car and put them
all in my car and went right just
charging them get out an angle grinder
he cut him in half the battery's out
legally legally if you put your scooter
on this sidewalk and just leave it there
forever you know without the expectation
of coming back to retrieve it you know
can so I'll take a few forfeit owner
should abandon it yeah if that's your
expectation but you have to the problem
is proving that that's someone's
expectations yeah exactly but that is
true if I park that scooter out there
after a certain period of time it could
be considered abandoned because no other
reasonable person would leave it out
there expecting to get it back exactly
the only happens it only I guess the
only thing working against that are the
the people who come and pick them up but
it's not even the same person
necessarily you don't necessarily get
the same scooter twice if you if you do
you know make your living charging them
but no one expects that those scooters
are intended to be abandoned that's the
problem yeah it would be pretty obvious
that this is just pure larceny but to go
back to the boosted rev it's a very
different product because those scooters
that you see on the streets are like
three to four hundred dollars a piece
and they usually break after about a
month that's how long they last
typically so this month twenty-nine days
but how long do you need to operate when
those even make your money back on one
of them more than 29 days yeah it's
something like twice that really a
little bit like they're bleeding money
right there in that problem or it's like
no one can raise their prices cuz
they're just hoping to outlast the
competition and it's a big problem
internally for all of them so they're
all trying to design their own scooters
that can actually last significantly
longer so that they can actually like
stay in the game but so sorry I just
to clarify yeah so all the scooter
companies right now all have really low
prices we're setting this expectation of
people to be able to travel for this
amount of money but then once they
outlast a competition everything's gonna
just rock it up in price that's what
they're waiting for I'm not even kidding
that's like legitimately what's
happening it's either that or they're
gonna go out of business it's actually
more than likely gonna end up becoming a
bit of a monopoly in certain cities and
yeah the prices are gonna go up you can
never expect the prices for this to ever
go down now yeah exactly
well I was just doing rough math there
basically if that is the shelf life of
them which makes total sense considering
our own experience here that means each
one is roughly an average of about three
and a half trips per day and each trip
being about a like what is it I a $3.00
there's that much a lot of them do get
used but the problem is that the people
who are using them because they don't
own them and they see it as like this
weird like anonymous thing oh my god
actually so they're like that was
something that companies didn't
anticipate was that just the level of
abuse that these things would get beyond
just average use because they were just
factoring in all right a person gets on
my bike on the street leaves it and when
you do that enough times eventually they
break but they don't take into the cow
the fact that was a fun ride off the
sidewalk with oh yeah you know stuff
like that yeah okay so by the way my
numbers are wrong it actually averages
out to more about like eight or nine as
a price per day okay so it's eight or
nine ten minute rides basically and like
we've we've gone on mega scooter trips
together that are longer than ten
minutes for sure but if you're actually
using a scooter to get to a destination
you're probably not gonna pick a place
that's more than like a ten-minute
scooter ride away and those are not
getting used eight times a day at that
at that time it's it's hard to say I
don't know
I don't cuz there's so many there's so
many you're always seeing people on them
like people do write them there's always
way more part than there are yeah so
it's it's hard for me to have a new
store still right okay so the boosted
Rev is kind of like a weird answer to
that because it's you can actually go
out and buy those scooters to begin with
but the problem is that
they're not that good in general they're
there like they work like if you've
never ridden an electric scooter before
or have one like there they're pretty
fun they're great and the booster drive
is the like is basically boosted's
answer to like alright let's say you
want to you you're not comfortable
riding a skateboard and you're are
comfortable with riding a scooter but
you want actual power you want an actual
vehicle that's why I've always argued
that the even though the one wheel is
expensive it's a vehicle like we've put
thousands of miles on these times and
like I think it's worth every penny so
if someone else feels similarly with the
scooter like here's a scooter that can
go 20 miles and will easily hit 24 miles
an hour which is by the way stupid fast
let's kill yourself fast yeah that's
like if you hit a bump and you go down
you are looking at serious absolutely
yeah these are helmet scooters it looks
like these are the answer for people who
want a good scooter yes it's a lot of
money that's more than the one wheels
were when everyone's complaining about
how how expensive the one wheel it's
more than the the the super 73 bikes
that we have which are like go on like
electric mini bikes but you can't put
this in your trunk sorry you can't put a
electric bike in your trunk unless it's
like one of those fold up on yes I don't
know at the end of the day I'm just
really excited cuz everyone has these
different ideas for what they think will
work and they make them and now you have
all these companies making those things
and we're slowly over the course of time
realizing and figuring out what works
versus what's the 6 pounds the next
electric vehicle tracking yeah so if
this is the answer it's not one wheel
it's not a scooter it's not a super 73
bike it's a backpack with a giant
battery in it that has cables running to
your hands and feet which have wheels
wheels shoes all four limbs on the
ground like a human truck
the future and it's small enough to you
can just drive a get onto a flight drive
there's no you don't have like an extra
vehicle because you are the vehicle I
want to make this I now really want to
make that yeah that's great oh my god
that's like battery powered Healy's one
of the other those already there sitting
in a drawer we never really do they're
really bad there's actually that video
by the way where you guys have been
quote-unquote battery-powered Healy's
Jake rides down the middle of Hunter
Street on the smooth part and he turns
the Karen says we call us the hunter
superhighway and that has forever stuck
with me every time I ride my one wheel
down I hear Jake's voice echo it's the
superhighway in my head every time
concrete section yeah part you're gonna
see around these parts yeah I used to be
a huge proponent for bird and I guess
everything else the same thing there's
those Healy's break dance on there the
same actually I would argue they are
more fun than the hoverboard craze that
we had three years ago but like it you
you can only really ride them in a
situation where you have like perfectly
smooth concrete like our studio here's a
great place to ride these and the
problem is that the novelty wears off
after about 10 minutes you're like okay
that was fun yeah at the end yep there's
a one wheel or any or a scooter or
something it's like it's it's it's fun
but it's also like it's a vehicle it
takes you from point A to point B it's
meant to get you places and clarify
things are just toys so if you could
design any electric personal vehicle
right okay that's actually feasible with
today's technology and it can't be the
one wheel well okay what would you
design what would it be
that's an easy answer for that one
dude a backpack quadcopter easy flight
it's a trade-off
I mean honestly I'm the way I see it the
one-wheel is kind of like the ultimate
vehicle for life for me because it's
like fundamentally there's not much
that's gonna change between now and
years was gonna get a little lighter is
gonna get more room just gonna get more
power no is the thing about riding a one
wheel is that it's it's it's so fluid
you feel like unicycle it electric
unicycle exists basically that's what
Jake's talking about he just wants a one
wheel with the next an extendable like
telescoping seat basically they have
those right now they are there that's
the main competition to a one wheel it's
like basically one wheel but the it's
it's it's taller and skinnier and it
goes between your legs like gizmo duck
and some of them have seats that you can
sit down on and yes those things that's
what future motorcycles have but we've
been dreaming of them forever
you know the futuristic motorcycle that
guy they look really silly I mean that
was actually pretty cool whoa whoa whoa
whoa that's my elbow you can buy a ride
[Music]
video of someone crashing this I would
love to see that how sad would this
video be if someone eating you don't
really underestimate the the skill
needed to balance on a one wheel device
like this because you can't like lean
forward too much right and these things
those ones that you sent on like that
are meant to go faster so the stakes are
raised pretty heavily so now you're
going thirty maybe forty miles an hour
which is that's the speed where if you
crash you actually die this is like some
like gizmo duck [ __ ] right here the
problem with all this is the is the
frame integrity you can't come up with a
device that's like allows you to sit
like a motorcycle or like a like a
unicycle that's what having a steel
frame that's why I believe so much in
the one wheel because the frame is your
knees right frame is like your body and
you use your knees to kind of have to
stand the whole time that's okay
but you get bonk Ito well you don't get
boggy til when you're going hard and if
you're going hard it's a good ride no
this is not what you should be doing oh
there you go that's a good he's got
demon armor on oh yeah yeah I mean I
used to love bird but I kind of feel
like oh wow I didn't know the public
sidewalk was a place where I could store
the things for my business yeah maybe I
could just be a couch out here with the
the assumption that no one should be
taking this like yeah game I'll just put
all this [ __ ] I go that's what I was
saying yesterday about how that's what
face
that's Facebook's that's like all every
tech company ever that's their mo yeah
it's like well this thing they'll agree
they'll be like oh well you know we
think that you know you should do this
and do that and then all these things
should happen and there should be public
everything and then they'll be like wait
is that public
oh let's put our own [ __ ] on there then
monetize it this is an interesting thing
that I was thinking about too which is
well once again it gets into the whole
YouTube copyright thing which seems to
be a topic on every single podcast but
at the same time it seems like there's
something new to talk about every week
on on this topic we're doing a natty
transition right now right but like
natty the one thing that I found
interesting was an article this it's not
the most recent one I think that's about
two three weeks ago but basically I
believe it was like genius the the music
lyric kind of website sorry we're
watching of watching people fall down
wield devices well since that does that
even being streamed I don't know Sam go
home with a story yeah sure
all right so so basically um this that
website genius basically makes lyrics or
publishes and posts lyrics for certain
videos and basically uh just like anyone
else who is effectively a content
creator basically a Google in its quest
for the to be the ultimate hub for
information you know when you search for
song lyrics still sometimes Auto draw
the best you know information
and so they started drawing their lyrics
from genius but the things that you know
like these websites have to support
themselves still throughout revenue and
so by stealing the click away from the
site they're stealing the the site's
revenue so they're you know it's it
defeats the whole business box and
Google's stealing it yeah basically and
and the way they found that out is
because it was they started using like
coded most Morse code through like
commas and periods put it they insert it
into there the lyrics mm-hmm and the
ones that were audited and despite
google denying it originally that it was
being pulled from their website if you
look at it the the commas and periods
actually ended up being identical it
being identical which is this Morse code
they put in there which was literally
read read a secret message that
basically states yo you're stealing our
[ __ ] okay but before we can even say
that before they keep the Morse code
spells Rhett red-handed basically and
so-and-so handed and then they saw if
Google would copy that for their lyrics
generation yeah and it did mm-hmm
meaning that Google was just sourcing it
from the site which is they're just
using BOTS to do that now
yeah here's the problem genius is
monetizing right no they not
it's just genius make money as a site
yeah ads on your site sure so they're
monetizing literary work that's already
copy written well sure but in the sense
that like what they're doing is they're
taking something that's not publicly
available as far like the lyrics are not
officially published for a lot of these
songs and so they go through they listen
to them they talked to the artists yeah
they figure out what exactly it's being
said and then they transcribe that but
the lyrics themselves are a literary
yeah but they're not they're not
charging for the lyrics themselves
they're just like they're just running
ads on a website that you visit right
but that's still and that's why they're
angry is that all the musicians could
argue that they're monetizing their
literary work but Google genius oh and
then but therefore Google and then
Google as well yeah so you're saying to
people I'm saying it's like people
one there no there they're claiming the
genius is claiming that - because mooing
their stuff but musicians could claim
also that genius is stealing their stuff
even if they are doing what well here's
a considered a public service yes but
the other thing is is that most a lot a
lot of artists are working directly with
genius so that's different posts that's
dead lyrics if you can get yeah if you
can have that in place with different
labels where genius will post your
lyrics and you'll make sure genius will
make sure that they're correct and
accurate yeah it has and they're not
just pulling it from every artist under
the Sun that's correct that and that's
what that's what's happening okay so
that is that is yeah then they would
actually have a claim for against good
exactly but I just find it's this is
what I'm talking about earlier what I
mentioned earlier which is this idea of
like like the value of data and
information right now which is like this
is like Google and Facebook you know in
these data hungry companies are so just
like yeah they're like ravenous for
information to the point where they're
gonna they're willing to break every
rule you know it's it's the whole ask
for forgiveness rather than permission
you know that's the bet is like the this
is the mo of of tech but it it's
question is has this been the mo of
America all along and yeah and why are
we complaining about Andy it's the mo of
humanity it is the mo of here is and so
we use we use the mo we're like hey
let's go shoot wherever we want with
them a video here and if someone stops
us will say oh sorry I'm back when
you're not here oops do you honestly
this is the epitome of the problem the
human condition guys yeah man this is
people taking stuff from other people go
leap and eventually leap an event and
it's okay sometime maybe it's not until
you're forced by more people then you
can fight off to agree with them so it's
more swatting so how's it getting better
for creators like us Jake thank you to
every ask things to help you see it due
to ongoing
Beus of the current youtube copyright
protection system ooh
youtube announced this week that it will
now require those people and
organizations variously filing copyright
claims to provide exact timestamps for
the parts of videos they're reporting
now repeated failure to provide accurate
manual time stands will revoke a user's
access to create manual claims creators
will then be able to use the Instituto
editing tools to either edit out mute or
dispute a claim now this is important to
us personally as well as to many other
creators out there one example that I've
talked to people about in the past has
been our Darth Sante video now we had
our friend Casey create an audio work
for that from scratch where the first
bit of the song used goes dunt da da da
duh duh duh duh dun dun dun dun dun and
that was enough that that last bit that
you did is a small market that was
enough for whoever owns that smaller
Warner which was down the street now
yeah eggs eggs so that was enough for
Warner Music or acclaim monetization on
that video now when I submitted my fair
use dispute they just simply knowing the
knowing how the YouTube copyright system
works they just said now we think it's
ours and then if I was to dispute that
again now we take a copy right so the
way that this currently works is if you
submit a fair use dispute and then the
party that thinks that they still have a
right says no it still ours and then you
come back and you decide to rebuttal and
move forward you get a copyright strike
against you right away and that only
gets removed when they finally release
their claim or a court decides that it's
okay so it's like bail jeez it's like
you're you're not guilty yet but you
came to the after is it an affidavit no
it's uh what's it called when you when
you go to plead I don't know you're the
lawyer
now I asked a man when you yeah it's
like you have to pay the bail and then
when you are found not guilty you get
the bail back gotcha
but you don't they don't just let you
out and make you pay later you know now
you know it's just like it comes down to
just like like what what what's what are
you gonna do what are you gonna do like
this is a problem that it's everyone
faces its no but this is YouTube's
trying to address it that's yeah YouTube
is now allowing creators to address that
time stamp and they can either like so
for example on Darth Santa we can go in
and we can mute the first four seconds
yes and then just say guess what guys we
muted out the section that you were
claiming for the entire video now the
monetization is ours yeah this is gonna
help creators at the end of the day yes
but like to preface that it they now
actually require anyone claiming
anything to specifies specifically which
seconds yeah they want a clinic got
rampant so like where they're like oh
now we think it's ours like now if we
were to file file or do that again
mm-hmm they wouldn't be able to be like
oh yeah no we still think it's ours
they'd have to go actually yeah
from seconds to 10-9 are our works and
you're like okay we muted it yeah um
oops I can't can't monetize that's why
that's gonna be better yes because they
the problem this was directly a result
of people saying hey this is music and
this is all because of the music
industry because the music industry has
like yeah well we haven't reacted to
music videos exactly because we tried
one time the Michael Jackson and we
uploaded it and then they claimed that
video the entire video yeah they claimed
the entire video they claimed we
uploaded 35 seconds non audio of just
the transitional effect but more
sycamore sequence that they use in that
video and then the videos 14 minutes
long and they claimed the entire video
is still claimed yes I submitted a fair
use dispute they said and they said that
you have and they still are can you edit
it out yeah that's how we can use now
you can better I mean could have before
just edit up the entire segment they
could have still claimed it like the
claim was already put on it you know so
now this now this requires you to put a
time stamp on it good and so it actually
is going to help out
a lot because things got really really
rampant from the music industry they
were they were trying to monetize and
claim everything exactly this is really
good for all creators on YouTube right
now this is really good cause my mind
like how I just gonna go off about the
music industry for two seconds here this
is just so symptomatic of that entire
industry like where they for example we
work we tried to work with this guy to
write a couple of songs for the corridor
crew and his label found out about it
and they said you can't do that unless
we monetize the videos those are our
videos now and it's like well we what we
wanted to do here's a simple solution we
like the videos that's where we live
that's our bread and butter so let me do
this why don't we create a bunch of
songs with this guy we'll post them on
audio only platforms and you can have
way more monetization there and we'll
push - it will push the Spotify will
push to Apple music will push to
wherever wherever you can get a check
from will do that okay and you can have
fit we can go 50/50 on there okay and
we'll do all the promotion and you just
help us work together to write this
stuff mm-hmm
and they were like no if we don't get
monetization of that video it's not
gonna happen on the video yeah on the
BIOS so and so they're just so they're
so sure like give us a cut of your
videos yeah they're so they're so static
and they've always had they always have
been which is exactly what led to the
original downfall of like the CD
industry yeah and which is what led to
digital downloads which is what led to
like people our age when the dawn of
that happening being so rampant about
not giving the music industry a dollar
right it was like now screw the music
industry they take money from us for
years that it added up yeah it's like
it's all these people who don't actually
make the product they're just in between
you and the product right trying to
constantly justify the decision wedge in
wedges find out about the guy yeah that
was the thing that happened cuz I know
we were trying to not let them find out
that's why we weren't actively trying to
know how to find out either but I mean
like we we didn't mention anything about
him so and then he was like yeah I
should talk to him but then his manager
found out you know
is manager check-in with the label and
then the label was like now because this
is how they they have to do everything
like this they can't you can't just make
a song it's not it doesn't work out I
feel like I feel like it you can you can
chart like the the progress of any
industry on that like a simple scale of
like at the beginning how hard you work
to like create things and like achieve
things and create unique and progressive
ideas and you know innovate and then the
scale at the halfway point starts to
turn into I got alright instead of like
how do I do this how how do i how do i
start burning down everything else
around me you know okay how do i
creating do i start destroying
competition for profit you know and like
the music is in is that is that it's
it's basically it's smack in the other
end of that's that the meter there where
it's just like it's in full like just
scorched earth policy at this point so
just to bring it back to a point we
previously talked about hasn't this has
isn't this oh it isn't boots isn't this
how it's always been
are you I'm a snake are you the boot are
you the big toe exactly I think we need
to leave it at that
yeah boy it's warm and humid here there
for a brief moment cuz they're gonna try
to fix our internet finally oh it's like
if walking into a pillow when you walk
into here because the air is so thick
can you go at least you can put a
sentence together suffering from literal
heatstroke
I still think this feels better than
doing the VFX react on that couch heat
is uniform I'm just like uniformly warm
and I don't really sweat too much so
it's not too bad words on that couch
it's not that like big leather couch
Georgia I feel fine every once and then
I stand up in my entire backside from my
mouth to my toes are just soaking wet
what if we got those gaming chairs that
have fans built into the seats we have
the [ __ ] we do have the blue but we
only have two it looks like we're sharin
just slowly turn down the volume
please consider subscribing to the
corridor cast YouTube's chance been good
it's been good so he's a good seeing you
guys here seeing the comments so yeah
drive pretty quiet now but tomorrow
maybe today dude one day turnarounds
that's right goodbye everybody
tools